la population en général c'est très peu
de choses l'agriculture au québec très
très peu en ce moment on réalise
vraiment qu'on n'est pas autonome avant
la cub et 19
on parlait pas beaucoup de tout
suffisance alimentaire au québec c'était
avant qu'on ait peur de manquer de
bouffe la crise de la coved 19 frappe de
plein fouet centaines de citoyens du
québec ont pris d'assaut les épiceries à
grande surface fait les toilettes
légumes surgelés les plusieurs rayons
sont pratiquement vides dans les
supermarchés et producteurs ne peuvent
compter sur la main d'oeuvre étrangère
un des services essentiels c'est nourrir
la population donc on veut est capable
de produire davantage localement
peut-être autonomes parce que nous avons
entendu le premier ministre vous avez
réagi
je trouvais ça très intéressant
la musique à mes oreilles de l'année
place c'est pas rien est ce que enfin
ils règnent plus monté de vraiment
revoir notre modèle agricole
il faut passer à l'action donc est ce
qu'on va faire avec les obstacles
maintenant parce que quand même une
structure en place qui n'a pour
d'exportation pour les spécialisations
ok complètement à l'encontre d'un
discours d'autonomie et de circuits
courts pourquoi en tant que peuple
important d'être autonome tout
simplement parce que tu ne dépend pas
des autres pour qu'on aurait avalé
centrale en quelques formules et cinq
six dernières années ont traversé une
sécheresse sans précédent des parlements
les des choux fleurs à 10 dollars on n'a
pas le contrôle surpris des animaux qui
nous donne d'ailleurs si c'est les
catastrophes dans ces régions sont en
mesure de nous croyons en notre nom
qui va nous l'a produit
[Musique]
distanciation physique oblige on est sur
les plaines d'abraham en savoie
rencontré patrick müller qui est un
économiste spécialisé dans le monde de
l'agriculture
est ce qu'au québec on est autosuffisant
quand on regarde la question de
l'autosuffisance moi je la regarde du
point de vue des statistiques de
consommation par rapport à ce que nous
produisons et quand je fais ce calcul là
j'arrive à peu près à 35 % de taux
suffisant s'alimente
35% ça veut dire qu'on produit le tiers
de ce qu'on mange on peut probablement
faire mieux mais comment pour comprendre
la situation au québec
il faut savoir d'où on vient dans les
années 50 y avait pas loin de cent
cinquante mille fermes au québec on
produisait environ les trois quarts de
notre alimentation
soyons honnête par contre l'assiette
était pas mal moins varié de terre dans
le gras et là vous les laissez cuire les
brass improbable après la deuxième
guerre mondiale le gouvernement a décidé
de moderniser l'agriculture d'une
agriculture de subsistance
on est passé en quelques décennies à une
agriculture industrielle
on ne mécanisée nos fermes spécialisées
la production les volailles résultat les
fermes ont grossi elles se sont acheté
entre elles elles sont devenues plus
productives
si bien qu'aujourd'hui il ne reste plus
que 30 mille fermes au québec c'est cinq
fois moindre dans les années 50 en 1998
grand virage lors du forum des décideurs
le premier ministre de l'époque lucien
bouchard décide que le porc du québec
pour nourrir la planète
le cheptel de porcs est passé d'un
million d'ha est à 51 7 millions
aujourd'hui dont les trois quarts sont
exportés 8% du port consommé sur la
planète vient du québec et c'est par là
il faut les nourrir
l'aliment privilégiée par l'industrie
c'est le mail sky1 mayes souvent
génétiquement modifiés destinés à la
consommation animale pour le maïs des
plus chers ont quitté les chaînes
résultat aujourd'hui les trois quarts
des terres du québec sont utilisés pour
nourrir les cochons et des vaches pas
des humains pour parler de ses choix de
société on s'envoie rencontré marcel
groleau c'est le président de l'union
des producteurs agricoles
il nous reçoit sur sa ferme à tête fun
c était quoi l'impact du forum des
décideurs sur notre agriculture c'est ce
qui a eu une influence non parce que le
signal était donné
on veut exporter davantage si on a la
filière porcine qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est notamment parce qu'à cette époque
là on a fait ce choix là
est-ce que ça a été une erreur vous
pensez de développer ses filiales n'ont
produit c'est dur de dire une erreur
c'est à l'époque il ya eu des erreurs
dans le développement rapide de la
filière qui ont dû être corrigés par la
suite notamment au niveau
environnemental
ces 52 e mail emploie aujourd'hui bien
rémunérés du secteur l'industrie pour
ses productions transformation de mon
point de vue moi je n'aurais pas soutenu
ça l'agriculture c'est pas seulement un
secteur économique c'est aussi quelque
chose de collectif qui organise notre
territoire qu'ils aménagent
ce saint pierre bonjour lui c'est michel
saint-pierre c'est un ancien sous
ministre de l'agriculture et l'actuel co
président de l'institut jean garon un
groupe d'observateurs sur les politiques
agricoles pour qu'on produit autant de
l'aes reproduite en maïs d'abord yeux
une la promotion de cette production là
vers les annie michaud y ait eu des
programmes de soutenir ce développement
l'assurance stabilisation l'asra a été
un élément important
pourquoi ces productions se sont
développées chez meubles organes d'une
parodie payant quand elle est témoin
elle était soutenue donc un producteur
moyennement pièce père dépôt dans ses
productions
donc c'est très sécurisant de fer sur le
poggio avez vous l'impression que ça a
façonné un peu le visage agricole tout à
fait tout à fait sûr c'est clair que ça
a façonné le ville avec le visage de
l'agriculture du québec
venez-vous accrue montréal et
drummondville et vous allez voir paysage
de maigres et sonia qui n'existaient pas
ce programme là est venu booster des
productions a de façon spectaculaire
moi c'est qu'on subventionne du maïs
transgénique il ya quelqu'un qui demande
essonne en société oh oui oui j'aimerais
qu'en tant que contribuables du québec
mon argent payé par les impôts servent à
produire du maïs transgénique qui vont
servir à nourrir des pauvres est
exportée au japon
si on veut faire une version pour la
confiance versier programme depuis des
décennies notre industrie c'est donc
tourner progressivement vers les marchés
internationaux de nos exportations et ce
qui serait souhaitable pour augmenter
notre autonomie d'arrêter nourrir les
autres pays d'abord ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que les accords de commerce ne
permettent pas ça nous sommes le canada
lié par quantité d'accords de
libre-échange qui nous disent que les
frontières doivent être aussi libre que
possible si on disait du jour au
lendemain à certains des pays qui ont
l'habitude d'acheter nos productions de
porc de certaines céréales certaines
légumineuses qu' on ne leur vend plus
ils auront aussi leur réaction ils vont
nous priver d'un certain nombre de
produits
donc il faudrait anticiper des réactions
très rapide et très vive de ceux qui
nous achètent normalement et à qui on
déciderait plus 22 mai matin lorsqu'on
parle d'auto suffisance on pense tout de
suite à la dépendance que l'on a
vis-à-vis des produits qui nous arrivent
de l'extérieur quand on est exportateur
et qu'on a beaucoup plus que ce que nous
pouvons consommer en interne on est
aussi dépendant nounou clear le marcheix
l'extérieur on ne contrôle pas si
subitement les japonais dessine que sa
perte en plus de manger du porc nourris
au maïs transgénique on fait pour être
me cauchon
l'autonomie alimentaire il faut la faire
de façon chirurgicale faut que ce soit
ciblée faut que ce soit fait
intelligemment dans les secteurs où on
est gagnant
vous oubliez d'essayer de le faire dans
les secteurs où on peut pas
compétitionner il faut surtout pas
perdre l'accès à des marchés où nous
faisons des gains importants et moi je
mettrais en garde les gens qui veulent
tourner à 180 degrés est ce que pour
avoir plus de produits locaux on est
obligé d'abandonner les produits qu'on
ex pas moi c'est clairement non on a
besoin d'avoir déposé à l'exportation
notre balance commerciale
agroalimentaire est positive au québec
donc c'est bon pour l'économie du québec
le québec au fait le choix nourrir la
planète avec 6 cochon mais ce qui est
encore possible d'espérer atteindre
l'autonomie alimentaire pour y arriver
on devra produire plus et diversifier
nos cultures
mais ça ne sera pas facile parce que
dans l'industrie agricole
il ya des règles incontournables au
québec on doit respecter ce qu'on
appelle les plans conjoints les plans
conjoints ce sont des ententes entre les
producteurs d'un même domaine
ils se mettent d'accord sur les
conditions de production et de mise en
marché en gros les producteurs d'un
domaine fixe les règles du jeu pour qui
veut entrer dans leur esprit le résultat
c'est que on retrouve maintenant des
plans conjoints qui sont contrôlés par
un très petit nombre de personnes
mais qui contrôlent la totalité de la
production d'hystérie trois en un
système agricole qui est complètement en
marge de tout notre démarche
parlementaire un plan conjoint a force
de loi et ne passe jamais par le
parlement y a pas un député que voté
pour l'adoption d'un plan conjoint sur
le lait ou le sirop d'érable
ça jamais passé à l'assemblée nationale
comment ces sexes et c'est un pouvoir si
fort que ça
certains plans conjoints vont assez loin
et encadre ce qu'on appelle la gestion
de l'offre pour produire du lait des
oeufs du lait ou des délits dont il faut
être titulaire de coton en bon français
il faut s'acheter un droit de produire
ça répond à l'imperfection des marchés
agricoles
c'est quand l'agriculture parce qu on
est isolés les uns des autres
souvent on surproduit s'entraîne la
chute des prix la gestion de la fpt on
décide ensemble ce qu'on produit en
fonction des mesures du marché lors de
cette façon là on empêche la
surproduction pour maintien des prix
intéressants
lorsqu'on a mis en place le système les
côtes ont été distribués aux joueurs de
l'industrie qui était présent à l'époque
aujourd'hui si un producteur souhaite
acheter un quota il doit négocier avec
les propriétaires qui en possède déjà
mais dans le monde la gestion de l'offre
liée à une petite brèche
c'est ce qu'on appelle le hors quota
sans être détenteurs de droits de
polluer les producteurs du québec
peuvent élever jusqu à 25 d'un dans 300
points et 100 poules pondeuses la
production de lait elle est interdite
sans avoir de quotas pour plusieurs c
seuil devraient être rehaussés
comme c'est le cas dans plusieurs autres
provinces canadiennes
[Musique]
john hollis on s'en va en parler avec
caroline pouvoir qui sait la présidente
de la cap et la coopérative pour
l'agriculture de proximité écologique la
ferme de caroline poirier produit des
paniers de légumes bio pour près de 300
familles sains et strip avec ses poules
pondeuses
elle tente de se diversifier à la
recherche de caroline attention à ta
tête
salut que j'en prenne fin de journée de
combien de paul ici c'est saint paul on
peut n'avoir plus ça
les fait super chaud c'est y en a
beaucoup qui sont restés en bas c'est
sûr que nous on a deux demandes assure
pas si la production de 100 poules on
serait capable de vendre facilement la
production de 200 poule donc ça nous
permettrait c'est sûr pour à peu près le
même temps d'entretien au niveau des
valeurs et des infrastructures qui sont
très semblables donc pas beaucoup de
coûts supplémentaires on serait capable
d'aller chercher plus de lait venus avec
200 poule parce que c'est les
productions qui sont quand même facile à
rentabiliser à petite échelle puis la
demande est excellente donc les gens
parfois ils vont choisir une firme qui
offre des oeufs bio avec les paniers
versus phonique et en offshore
c'est aussi qu'on crée des attentes du
condé soit des clients donc et les gens
si ça va être au top au panier bâillon
passé aux us à leur femme
déception
parce que ça serait pour vous acheter du
quota non ça serait pas acheter du côté
du qatar ça vaut très cher premier amant
puis deuxièmement ça souvent en grandes
tranches puis ça se vend très peur j'ai
eu très peu de tractations de cauter sur
les marchés dans le cas de la poule
pondeuse ils sont 104 si je me trompe
pas 204 personnes qui détiennent le
quota pour des poules pondeuses et si un
nouvel arrivant veut arriver et avoir
plus que les 100 poules pondeuses
autorisé actuellement mais il doit payer
245 $ par poules pondeuses 245 pièces
pour une poule 2 et proches attendent
encore les pas nourrir et pas vendus et
des voix fait la mise en marché juste
pour le droit 2 et vous payez ça des
gens qui n'ont pas une somme à payer ce
côté là où qu'ils n'ont pas payé à ce
prix là mais qui sont assis sur ce droit
de produire ces du conflit d intérêt
structurelles est ce que ce serait
souhaitable qu'au québec on augmente ce
côté là selon vous d'un point de vue
économique
ya pas vraiment de conséquences sur les
filières de d'ouvrir un petit peu le jeu
à des producteurs de nouveaux
producteurs parce que c'est tellement
massif comme coproduction queue leu leu
en ouvrant la possibilité à des
producteurs de produire par exemple 2000
poulets par an au lieu de 300 ou 500
poules par an au lieu de 100 on
représente rem quoi qu'il arrive moins
de 1% de la production totale du québec
la diversifier notre offre
ça nous permet de rentabiliser notre
mise en marché donc si on laissait un
peu de lest puis qu'on les disait ben à
la relève aux gens confirme diversité on
voit quand même aussi les seuils de
façon à ce qu'ils puissent aller
chercher une partie de la hausse de la
consommation mais ça nous donnerait de
l'air pourquoi ne dans l'essonne et plus
bas au canada parce que c'est contrôlé
par les monopoles les personnes d'autres
pour que les deux autres choses la façon
dont les plans conjoints et les coteurs
sont gérés de façon privée ils sont en
conflit d'intérêts moi je prends
l'exemple
c'est comme si vous demandiez à 1,06 g
est d'accord pour laisser une plus
grande part de marché à wal mart
évidemment la réponse de jéhovah est non
le monopole dont pas au maximum la place
c'est le monopole de l'ue et l'union des
producteurs agricoles lui poste
syndicaux qui existe depuis 1972 la loi
ou québec stipule qu'il ne peut exister
qu'un seul syndicat agricole la loi du
bic ont fait un monopole
il n'y a qu'une seule association que
doit représenter la totalité des
fermiers et clp 1
c'est un peu le modèle allemagne de
l'est cela c'est démocratique mais il ya
juste un parti au pouvoir
il prédit que dans ni dans
l'enseignement ni dans le domaine de la
construction et tout et tout et il n'y a
pas juste un syndicat d'agriculture
ailleurs qu'au québec il ya de justin
est d'ailleurs tous les programmes tous
les programmes agricoles gouvernementaux
que ce soit au niveau provincial ou
fédéral sont conditionnels au paiement
de la caution libère est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est toujours d'actualité
d'avoir un monopole syndical au québec
bon j'aime pas le monopole on a une
accréditation syndicale comme l'union
des artistes essentiellement la même
chose
est-ce que ça répond aux besoins
d'aujourd'hui moi j'irai plus que j'aime
plus on divise les producteurs plus les
producteurs sont vulnérables dans
l'apparat la taille des marchés et
donnez moi un exemple dans l'histoire ou
la division est préférable à l'union moi
je vois à l'intérieur de l'union
beaucoup de des changes puis ces
échanges ne permette à chacun d'évaluer
mieux comprendre l'eau plutôt que si on
était dans des organisations séparés ou
isolées m'at on s'écoute pas on se parle
mais lui paiera des compétences
absolument il représente un modèle je
t'ai fait puis puis on n'est pas là pour
abolir du ps et pas la question mais
justement c'est qu'ils ne représentent
qu'un modèle qui ont beau prétendre
représenter plusieurs points de vue mais
je vais être très très clair là dessus
comment pouvez vous plaidez pour le
libre échange et l'exportation et en
même temps plaidé pour la culture de
proximité
le quelque part là il ya une aberration
branchez vous vous voulez exporter ou
vous l'ignorez à notre population
on peut pas défendre les deux on peut
pas à la fois faire la défense de
l'industrie du maïs et du soya
qu'utilise des ogm
et en même temps vouloir faire la
défense du bio
[Musique]
lupe a de bonnes raisons de défendre le
modèle actuel il est payant au québec la
majorité des grandes productions sont
soumises à ces plans conjoints qui
prévoit des cotisations versées aux
syndicats une aile entière 40% de ses
revenus
c'est tous les plans conjoints qui sont
contrôlés par les filières de lutter en
conflit d intérêts des détenteurs de
quotas qui décide qui va être la relève
qui pourrait peut-être acheter du coton
après examen mais c'est une aberration
donc les plans conjoints ne devrait pas
être gérée par une entité syndicale
c'est un contrat social le jeu ces
enveloppes c'est pas un con tre privé
vous avez lu paix avaient toutes les
fédérations qui sont les les mandataires
et les gestionnaires des plans conjoints
ça fait vous le véritable moteur de
l'agriculture non et ce afin de nous le
gardien des intérêts des producteurs
agricoles et pas le moteur de
l'agriculture est ce que nous payons
amène trop la réponse est oui parce
qu'ils représentent pas des couettes
mans cette diversité sa pluralité de
l'agriculture que tout le monde souhaite
d'une foule mais ils ont nos par l'art
en main et quand arrive un événement
comme celui qu on convient que tu elba
avec des risques de rupture
d'approvisionnement
on n'a pas omis les agricultures
généralement qu on en plus souvent au
président du pays oscar wendt
c'est pas la première fois que la
question du monopole de l'upa et
soulevées déjà dans les années 2000 un
important rapport sur l'avenir de
l'agriculture avait remis en question la
pertinence d'un syndicat unique et ce
rapport tout nous intervenons nous en
ont parlé
le rapport pronovost si celui de la
commission sur l'avenir de l'agriculture
déposé en 2008
c'est michel st-pierre qui était sous
ministre de l'agriculture à l'époque les
commissaires ont tenu une centaine de
rencontres et reçu 720 mémoire
après trois ans de travaux ils ont remis
au gouvernement un rapport surnommé le
rapport pronovost sorte les limites mais
aborde tous les volets votre chiot la
mise en marché des structures de mise à
marché et au fait vous comment dire
recommandations dont je dirais le thème
principal est la multiplication des
modèles la pluralité des bonis puisque
les besoins changent qu'il nous semble
normal que l'agriculture et
l'agroalimentaire évolué avec eux le
commissaire principal de voeux le
président monsieur pronovost dit très
clairement le québec agricoles manquent
d'oxygène
le québec agricole étouffe sous le seuil
carquin c'est les plans conjoints
c'est une influence démesurée de l'upm
il faut ouvrir le système pour faire de
la place aux nouvelles réalités et ce
cadre bien parce qu'actuellement c'est
son discours si on lit aujourd'hui la
est encore auteur d'actualité
des rapports pronovost c'est mon étoile
za dans le rapport pronovost ce qu'on
trouve c'est vraiment tout le spectre
de ce à quoi on doit s'attarder
pour avoir une agriculture prospère
et avoir une agriculture qui est durable
pour moi c'est des indicateurs de
direction venait à mon bureau
ce rapport est encore un petit bijou
gagne heureusement les mythes côté
pourquoi ils déplaisait sur un point
c'est très clair sur les 49
recommandations qu'il faisait un aveu
qui déplaisait souverainement oui je
réponds mieux qu elle me sens que les
bancs d'école si des recommandations à
46 ans qui visait à avoir une
représentation multiples pièges qu'un
scientifique ci avait deux associations
on peut avoir un débat plus public d'un
fonds plus ouvert plus transparent
la recommandation sur l'accréditation de
luppé 1 et venus occulter les autres
recommandations de ce rapport et sans
scanner quel rapport à nouveau fait
parce que s'ils avaient pu
recommandations là on aurait pris le
temps d'étudier les autres
recommandations le rapport pronovost
votre étoile du nord était assez clair
on devait remettre en question le
monopole syndical allez vous le faire
c'est pas quelque chose leur soutien à
la junte au départ et puis je vous
dirais moi à l'intérieur de mon mandat
c'est certainement pas quelque chose qui
fait partie sont peu de rouge veut
investir mais nrj puis cela mon équipe
on en croit mme hama
[Musique]
pour plusieurs la mise en place des
recommandations du rapport pronovost
permettrait la diversification de la
production et faciliterait la peine de
l'autonomie alimentaire des
recommandations qui touchent notamment
la question des abattoirs depuis une
vingtaine d'années leur nombre a fondu
au québec pendant la crise la qu'ovide
les abattoirs n'arrivait plus à suffire
à la demande
et on a craint de devoir et en asie des
milliers de porcs les animaux véritable
pile ça crée un gros problème pour les
producteurs lord est rendu là près de
5000 par alors ça devient une situation
critique pour nous autres
la diminution du nombre de vos droits
renforcés les petits éleveurs loin des
marchés à faire abattre leurs bêtes à
des centaines de kilomètres de chez eux
pour plusieurs les abattoirs de
proximité et l'abattage à la ferme
doivent revenir à l'agenda pour
permettre la rentabilité des élevages à
petite échelle mais aussi pour rendre le
québec plus résilient si on avait des
abattoirs dans chacune des maisons au
québec je pense qu'on serait beaucoup
plus résilient à ce niveau là mais je
pense aussi qu'on a fait rêver à un
service comme extrêmement important qui
permettra des firmes d'envisager de
faire des productions animales qu'elles
ne font pas actuellement parce qu'elles
se trouvent trop loin des bus d'abattage
qui nuiraient incroyablement à la
rentabilité de leurs opérations
on ne peut pas parler d'autonomie
alimentaire
sans parler des travailleurs du québec
d'ici quelques mois
le problème numéro un c'est la main
d'oeuvre étrangère qui risquent de faire
défaut faute de personnel il doit
faucher cder et sont donc obligés de
détruire en partie du relais code quand
les frontières se sont fermées aux
travailleurs étrangers
on s'est rendu compte que les fermes du
québec était dépendant surtout les
grandes fermes maraîchères qui s'appuie
sur la main d'oeuvre étrange si la
demande
ce sont six fermes là qui craignait de
jeter leur école qui devait nourrir
en ce moment on réalise vraiment con et
potton nos produits viennent d'ailleurs
puisqu'on produits au québec on a besoin
d étranges dans nous on a pas les gens
ici pour occuper ces emplois nets c'est
du travail que des québécois veulent pas
faire moi je crois que ce qui va
remplacer les travailleurs étrangers
ce sera pas des travailleurs québécois
ça va être l'automatisation plus la
mécanisation pourtant de la main
d'oeuvre agricole viande mais pas où
l'industrie la voudrait la pénurie de
travailleurs est beaucoup moins forte
dans le nom des petites fermes
diversifiés comme celle de caroline
poirier
ce sont les jeunes la relève agricole
qui comblent besoin de travailleurs
en maraîchage bio diversifiée je pense
qu'on a la plus grande part de la relève
agricole au québec en ce moment c'est
une élève qui est jeune qui est motivée
qui est fort mais qui est innovante qui
est prête à relever des défis
le problème de main d'oeuvre dans
l'agriculture conventionnelle est
récurrent il a raison pourquoi ils ont
besoin de travailleurs qui viennent de
l'étranger succéder si des emplois qui
sont pas très stimulant donc c'est très
répétitif
si on veut des fermes sont stimulants il
faut que le modèle d'affaires soit
diversifiée comme nous on a 40 légumes
différents donc très vive sur une ferme
comme ici le c'est quand même
fantastique puis aussi nous on fait de
la vente directe
on rencontre les clients s'il ya tout
cet aspect là de relations humaines qui
fait en sorte que c'est un beau métier
et dans l'agriculture industrielle sont
les évacuer ça leur coup c'est que les
gens se sont désintéressés de
l'agriculture
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu aimes dans le fait de
travailler dans la terreur comme ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on doit faire
c'est une responsabilité en tant que
société en tant qu'être humain il faut
qu'on le fasse comme il faut de manière
respectueuse de l'environnement et des
gens notre enjeu est vraiment au niveau
salarial
parce qu'on se le cachera pas le
maraîchage on est en compétition directe
avec tous les légumes qui viennent
l'outre-mer qui ont pas les mêmes normes
sociales et environnementales que nous
et aucune barrière tarifaire donc nous
on se retrouve à est directement en
compétition
puis pour les gens qui veulent faire une
carrière en agriculture avec nous 13 14
15 $ de l'heure c'est très difficile de
vivre avec ceux à long terme d'abord une
famille de faire six mois par année sur
l'assurance emploi
jusqu'où on peut augmenter le salaire
des québécois et si les fraises du
québec se nomme des fraises importées
ça va être compliqué c'est les tomates
en serre au mexique mais ils sont
produits par des travailleurs mexicains
qui gambien un cinquième de ce que les
coriums ex qu'un gagne quand ils
viennent travailler chine pendant le
moment où les gens doivent apprendre le
vrai coût de l'heure de leurs légumes
on va avoir besoin d'un maître de l'état
une subvention pour nous a aidé à
soutenir des salaires qui sont des
saints les écoles d'agriculture bio sont
pleines et jeunes veulent faire
l'agriculture il me fait à qui ils
veulent commencer petit ils veulent pas
ta grosser avec le temps mais ils
veulent pas reprendre des grosses
entreprises que ton père ton grand père
a mis 50 ans a monté plus tôt tu arrives
pas ouf
c'est une 5 millions de chiffre
d'affaires à gérer c'est pas la même
chose que ses amis
si cette relève souhaite un jour voler
de ses propres ailes et devenir
propriétaire d'une entreprise elle va
devoir trouver des tas et ça c'est
actuellement un problème au niveau de
l'achat des terres
les prix sont très élevés les petits
lots sont très peu disponibles donc elle
se retrouve à soi devoir acheter quelque
chose de beaucoup trop gros beaucoup
trop cher puis ce nom il se trouve à
être en compétition sur le marché des
plus petits lots avec des gens qui sont
peut-être retraités ou en pré retraite
ou stocker thaïlande est tout de suite
recherché par des gens qui veulent avoir
un pied à la campagne et c'est pas
nécessairement pour faire l'agriculture
personnes préretraitées cammas et son
capital puis relève agricole qui sort de
l'école et qui oppose grand chose en
poche on n'est pas capable de
compétitionner à ce niveau la loi sur la
protection des terres agricoles dit que
si une ferme achète le lot voisin et que
le lot une première commune avec son lot
actuelle automatiquement les deux lots
fusion donc ça fait des années que la
loi existe et qu'elle est appliquée de
cette façon alors donc les lots au
québec n'ont fait que grossir
donc maintenant les gens qui veulent
acheter un plus petit lot se trouvent
dans plusieurs régions devant
l'impossibilité ou presque de le faire
ou encore doivent aller devant la régie
pour demander le morcellement mais on
s'entend que son frère une barrière
édition
la protection étoiles quand la loi a été
écrite dans un contexte il ya 40 ans il
ya certainement des ajustements qui
doivent être fait en même temps il ya
comme un contrat social avec la loi sur
la protection du territoire agricole sur
la protection
malgré cette voie là il y en a plein des
terres agricoles à chaque année qui sont
perdus à l'urbanisation
donc il faut pas ouvrir toutes grandes
les portes mais il faut réfléchir
intelligemment de façon à permettre à la
relève
adapté à ses rêves facile option
[Musique]
depuis les années 50 le territoire
cultiver du québec aurait perdu près de
400 mails hector c'est l'équivalent de
huit fois le territoire de l'île de
montréal
lupe à dénoncent l'urbanisation depuis
longtemps comme principal coupable et
elle n'a pas tort
les villes ont empiété sur les terres
mais le monde agricole a aussi sa part
de responsabilité
lorsqu'on a décidé de mécaniser nos
fermes les petites terres qui n'était
pas adapté à l'agriculture et du trille
elles ont pris le port les agriculteurs
les ont abandonnés
trouve que ça manque de musique on prend
maintenant la route vers saint valérien
dans le coin de rimouski pour rencontrer
donald dubé qui en a long à dire sur le
sujet quand on roule au bas saint
laurent
c'est pas difficile de trouver des
terres abandonnées juste dans la région
y en a où 8000 ha si l'équivalent de
onze mille terrain football
techniquement on appelle ça des terres
en friche qu'on appelle la crèche c'est
la forêt qui se réapproprient la prairie
qui peut plus john a
ici c'est une très vieille sagesse
chapeau a été renouvelé depuis 15 ans je
faucherai chaque année pour éviter qu
avec la forêt reprennent sont durs pour
continuer d'exporter tout en devenant
plus autonome on va peut-être devoir
remettre ces termes la culture puis sa
seat combo de donald dubé si on continue
encore juste d'un genre zine qui ne se
dit que ça serait donc bien gagner en
autonomie souvient l'un deux ans 5 ans
10 ans pendant ce temps là ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est quand r&d vitesse grand
v
c'est effectivement un potentiel qui
dort me fait peur aux normes il est en
train de se dégrader
ça va coûter énormément d'argent
seulement menés on allume les oreilles
on a besoin de cet argent pour produire
davantage
ok on lime en production ben non propos
et mettre en production pour l'année
o'neal années 2000 année 3 parce que ça
va être partiellement reboiser
naturellement c'est votre devenus des
friches
donc ça diminue notre possibilité de
gagner en autonomie mais un peuple qui
veut peut être pas noble s'en fout tout
seul mais pour beaucoup de ses terres il
faudra que québec intervienne si on veut
les remettre en culture en 2004
le gouvernement a instauré un moratoire
sur le développement du territoire
agricole l'agriculture industrielle
renvoyait tellement de phosphore dans la
nature que le gouvernement a décidé de
limiter l'étalement des terres dans de
nombreuses régions au québec les terres
abandonnées avant le moratoire ne
peuvent tout simplement pas être remises
en culture
aujourd'hui on a réglé nos problèmes de
phase iii mais le moratoire lui perdu
donc sûr ça fait des années nous qu'on
demande la levée du moratoire sur les
terres en culture au québec pour qu'on
puisse au moins conserver les superficie
actuelle parce qu'actuellement on
régresse
on construit des routes l'étalement
urbain se poursuit donc la superficie
cultivée au québec depuis 2004 et rouge
les ou en régression donc oui il faut
lever ce moratoire leur pee wee faut
investir dans ces termes mais les bonnes
terres d'abord parce qu'il faut aussi
dire que toutes les terres en friche ne
sont pas nécessairement des tas de
qualités leur agricole
on les attend les grands industriels une
forme de proximité en région qui veut
alimenter cette en 1975 en abitibi
le cinéaste pierre perrault de louer
nerf est en train de filmer ce qui ce
rôle lot de milliers d'hectares de
terres agricoles au québec on veut y
cultiver des épines
quarante ans plus tard la plantation sur
des terres agricoles
il s'en fait encore au québec dans bien
des cas ces subventionné c'est ce qui
est arrivé à la terre voisine de donald
dubé de créer ces terres l'eau ça
demande une énergie dont le brésil parce
que il ya 120 ans et plus des boisés
travail sous forme de manque de respect
pour nos ancêtres bâtie dans les années
70 ce matin
mentionnait la plantation d'arbres sur
les terres agricoles
oui il ya eu des erreurs de fait dans
ces années là c'est sûr on fait la même
chose en abitibi actuellement l'abitibi
c'est un des endroits où il ya les
meilleures terres au québec on sait
qu'avec le réchauffement climatique
c'est un leurre vont pouvoir produire
plus aussi alors est-ce que c'est loger
avec la demande alimentaire qui
croissance l'augmentation de population
non ce polo gti la perte de vitalité de
notre territoire agricole a aussi eu des
conséquences importantes dans le monde
rural au bas-saint-laurent 80% la vie
économique des villages tourner autour
de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui ça représente moins de 16%
je pense qu'on a vu l'agriculture
uniquement comme un secteur économique
et on n'a pas assez pensé à son impact
sur l'aménagement du territoire
c'est dans les villages avec des
quincailleries avait des
stations-services y avait des épiceries
c'est parce qu'il y avait de l'activité
agricole aujourd'hui ça existe plus
c'est pas étonnant de voir les villages
en région se dévitalise et les jeunes
ont pas envie de rester dans leurs
villages par ce qui a pu lui commerce
epub ligne et sociaux forts entre les
citoyens ce grand projet d'autonomie
alimentaire l'eau quand je dis lui que
ça ratisse très large des grands enjeux
de société c'est que si on se met à
produire davantage on va voir des firmes
comme la mienne se multiplier sur le
territoire ce que ça vaut faire c'est
savoir dynamiser
la campagne est magnifique c'est
l'agriculture qui va ramener les gens la
campagne pour la grosse entreprise qui
pour les industries la succursale a
toujours été de savoir venir sur un bras
québécois la première épouse si je vous
ai commencé au monde et de faire paître
son patrimoine lui donne à manger du pop
art rock qui cultivent qui explique mon
but à l'extérieur est ce que vous y
croyez
québec autonome en alimentation un
québec qui peut être voudra augmenter
son autonomie
c'est possible un québec qui voudra
peut-être prendre l'habitude d'acheter
un peu plus québécois dans les secteurs
où nous nous mettons en compétition avec
d'autres ça c'est tout à fait possible
il ya entre autres un certain nombre de
comportements que les consommateurs
pourraient être adoptées la première
chose à faire c'est d'éduquer les gens
ne dit que les gens sur la saisonnalité
notre agriculture sur le fait qu'on peut
pas offrir tous les produits en tout
temps pendant la saison de façon
écologique et de façon durable
donc il va falloir aussi que les gens
apprennent à adapter leur alimentation à
la saison puis y'a pas si longtemps et
aux 25 30 ans ont mangé de cette façon
là les gens célèbres et ça ça faisait
partie de notre culture kullmann
d'impact fouquereuil un peu consommateur
du producteur pour convenir d'un contrat
social avec le citoyen restons ils vont
nous dire hey et produit par la cadoule
on attend vos preuves n'est pas accepter
mes idoles asafa sur un plan pédagogique
d'éducation qui sont là aussi d'une
antenne comme étant un marathon il faut
sortir d'une logique de beaux prix à
tout prix parce que ça a un coût salut
un coup sur la santé les cours d'eau
salée un coup les écosystèmes camps ont
pris un méchant coup vite et je me nomme
fatah ou aimer les gens n'ont pas les
moyens mais si c'est plus ou moins
réelle
c'est les gens le moyen de le faire de
choix au québec tout un pays très très
riches mais l'essentiel de ce qu'on
dispose comme moyen l'utilisent pour
acquérir des biens
c'est ça notre priorité la nourriture sa
ligne
les une responsabilité une très grande
responsabilité du loup en a marre on
veut augmenter notre autonomie alimata
qui doit devenir le chef d'orchestre
paul deux ministères mais doit gouverner
il doit en avant du peloton et indiquer
la voie à suivre
la culture plurielle dans un peu nouveau
parler d'elle avant tout à nos portes
j'ai pu le faire il faut qu'on devienne
cette europe de l'amérique nord qu'on se
démarque comme ce père vient manger bien
vie sociale exclut pas d'investir dans
les plus grosses fermes pour
l'exportation et au moins assurons-nous
qu'au québec on a une petite agriculture
qui est forte si bien enraciné qu'un
code crise climatique de taipei
pandémique qui vont continuer dopé avec
ni frontière ni la culture de demain là
ça commence aujourd'hui avec les choix
qu'on fait à nantes est forte on ressort
elle bien cool vous concert en concert
le pied en cette période qu il doit
aimer notre documentaire tu devrait
assurément aimer les autres contenus de
carbone rends toi sur radio canada.ca
barres obliques carbone mais tu peux
aussi nous trouver un petit peu partout
leur facebook instagram youtube thunder
a peut-être potente le back up pour un
des réalisateurs oui là mais ça c'est
une autre histoire bref on est partout
des très rares opportunités que cela
passe aussi en nettement moi je veux
toujours être long
une population
[Rires]
[Musique]